>> So when should an entrepreneur
start thinking about accessibility?
>> From the beginning, immediately.
Even just during the product
conception phase,
it's critical to be thinking about this.
You should be thinking about how
could this really benefit and
improve the life of a user with or
without a disability?
Thinking about how can my product
be used in various situations?
Things like that are very important.
I think a good example is Google Books,
which was became really
beneficial to everyone in that.
Now that all of these books that
were tucked away in libraries across
the world were digitized and
you could see them just by
typing in your computer.
So now only is it beneficial to you and
I, but
folks that use screen readers now.
They are able to use these, have these
books read to them via screen reader,
which in the past,
they would have to wait for
a braille version, which are very
costly and time consuming to get.
So this is a great example of
why it's important to think of
these things early.
>> So how do you go about designing for
all users and
what sort of lessons learned from Google
Books or maybe other digital projects
should entrepreneurs be aware of and
know about?
>> So, I think the first
thing is to just for you and
your team members to become familiar
with accessibility basics and
most importantly is understanding
the needs of users with disabilities.
So when you're starting out any project,
you want to reach out to users that
you think will be your end user and
understand their needs,
their challenges, their pain points.
And so this is the exact same thing
you want to do with people with
disabilities.
So reaching out to folks
that you feel like,
meet your target audience that also
have impairments is really important and
the insights that you
gain are invaluable.
The other thing you want to do is
become more familiar with assistive
technologies.
So, assistive technologies are tools
that a number of people use to just
kind of help them achieve the same
task that other people would with just
a little bit of assistance.
So examples of this are closed
captioning in videos,
where you can see the words
that are being said.
You see those typed at
the bottom of those.
There are magnification
devices that people with
low vision might need to use.
There are screen meters,
which essentially read the contents
of the screens to the users.
So you don't have to become
an expert on these, by any means,
because that would take forever.
But just understanding the basics,
as well as watching and
observing somebody use these.
Specifically, watching them, use the
technologies with your product is again,
it's one of the most eye opening
experiences I've ever had.
And then I think another thing to keep
in mind is that there are a number of
online resources for
accessibility design guidelines,
that give you lots of points of what
to consider when you're designing.
So an example might be,
when you're in the visual design stage,
you want to be thinking
about good color contrast.
So that users with low vision can
actually read what's on the screen or
on the page.
When you're thinking about interaction
design, you want to ensure that again,
what we talked about before where the
keyboard users that only use a keyboard
are able to complete all of the tasks
that they're trying to achieve.